so now i want to show you another um
type of turtle program we can send to
the to the uh plotter machine you're
there waiting for your next job yeah
and we're going to continue with this
idea of just giving it a list of angles
to turn through and i just need to find
some source of
angles and i thought maybe let's look at
the digits of numbers like pi and that
kind of thing here we have our original
thing where we started exploring the
euler spiral like what if i just start
sending the digits of pi
uh 846.
wow you know that many off by her i know
more than that but
the next one's a two okay yeah he always
needs no one more
if i sent this this would just be like
three radians one radian and stuff it i
think what would make more sense would
be to do well what i've marked up on on
this here
i've split this into ten directions
so
if i do for the first three if i do one
two three i could that might make more
sense so i'll be turning three tenths of
a full turn
and then i'll turn
you know then i'll turn one tenth then
four times one ten five nine and then
we'll see what see what picture it gets
drawn so does that mean one will be
36 degrees yeah okay yeah we're doing
multiples of 36 degrees so yeah let's
put in that 36 degrees
it would have been pointing this way and
it turned back three tenths to go up
this way
and then it here it turned just 36
degrees the smallest amount it can turn
and so on
[Music]
here when it got to 5 you'll notice that
it just did a
180 degree turn
because 5
tenths is a half any time you see a 5
that means it goes back
so if i see two fives basically it
doesn't do anything right
yeah so
let's draw more we're going to stick to
base 10 to start with and and then it
will do this picture uh it'll plot the
turtle drawing for that number
[Music]
so here we have pi
in base 10 and let's do 3
000 steps of pi i got this picture here
kind of like a fractal island or
sort of wild walk
going around everywhere let's do more
digits see what it looks like so here's
ten thousand
our original picture i think was up in
this corner here now it's branched off
and gone over here
[Music]
20 000
100 000
so like here is some
way of visualizing the digits of pi
let's just sort of come out from playing
around with turtle programs
[Music]
i've got so many questions coming to my
mind like
where will it ultimately go will it ever
come back to the start will every
possible shape be formed at some point
like you know you know you know how they
say the monkey's writing shakespeare
will you eventually draw the mona lisa
just by luck right yeah yeah i have
those same questions as well one
conjecture about pi is that it's normal
the digits of pi are normal meaning that
every possible sequence that you could
think of
zero one not two three up to 9 would be
in the digits of pi
that i guess that means if you had some
shape that you could draw with 36
degrees turn you would expect that
shape to eventually show up in this
drawing
i guess you don't know exactly where in
the paper it would be
right so i'm so i
i don't know if you would expect after
drawing for infinitely long would you
just have like a black sheet of paper
it's fully filled in with ink
when you get a very long string of
zeros you'll get like really long
straight lines long straight line yeah
another question i think is natural to
ask is like if i gave you this picture
could you have worked out the digits of
pi
right or if i sent someone this is like
a secret message or i broadcast this
across the universe as like a sign up
there's some intelligence on earth would
it be a good way to show like hey we
know about pi let's do three thousand so
we get this kind of like
dancing off away from the main kind of
hub
[Music]
this is pi base 10
almost 3 000 digits base 10 is arbitrary
right so i mean you want to try a
different base got one in mind well
let's go base 3. base three is cool
so let's let's change the base to three
and let's boost up to ten thousand
points so one cool thing about base
three is that our our turns are going to
be uh 120 degrees
that means that we're going to be
constrained to this triangular grid
triangles that tessellate the plane
whereas with base 10
we have this weird 36 degree angle it's
kind of like pentagons right and
pentagons don't tile the plane so yeah
you can
get a real mess you're always going to
have sort of collections of triangles if
you use base three so will base four
give us squares uh
yeah that's right
so now we've got squares i like this as
maybe
if i needed to generate some kind of
like roads for a zoomed out city in a
video game or something you might
you know create a network like this they
look like world maps to me yeah yeah
some people say they're kind of like
like ways to generate an island
it looks like japan maybe we're getting
more uh
just a hundred thousand in base four
[Music]
so i'm i chose pie because i want like
an infinite list of turns that is just
going to spew out the mona lisa at some
point
less interesting digit sequence would
just be rational number so let's change
pi to
a seventh i like a seventh because it's
zero point one four two eight five seven
one four two eight five seven if you do
that enough you're just gonna end up
back where you started in the same
orientation and you're gonna create a
rotationally symmetric picture like this
you make it like one over some bigger
prime
like i guess one one nine is a prime
probably then you get a like a a more
detailed but still rotationally
symmetric picture it's kind of
a nice way to see a stark difference
between rational numbers and irrational
numbers
do more rational numbers so we try e
so let's do e
base
a hundred thousand
[Music]
there you go that's e
what's going on here that's a cool
little place
there's a little lagoon yeah this seems
like an unlikely configuration that
looks like britain up there yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah we're here right now yep
yeah
yeah
i like
uh golden ratio
so what you got square root of five plus
one in some sense the most irrational
number
i don't know if it gives a
sort of more squiggly map but it looks
cool to me
[Music]
imagine if you just put some arbitrary
number in one day like randomly and
pressed it and your face appeared yeah
or
conversely could somebody send me the
number that draws my face
this is the fame and point to six nines
nine nine nine nine nine nine so that
won't be beaten there is a string of
seven threes
but that takes another seven hundred and
ten thousand digits so we'll be nearly
three quarters of the way down the mila
pi before we find a longer string of the
same digit and the first one is within
the first two meters